okay so this is one plus one this is
bullets uh first of five
let's go i do encourage people to watch
both streams at once
oh we're gonna play the same thing we
played earlier i guess
do i play d5 swinger probably not just
stick with the
the same idea
okay
so it's going to be kind of a a peaceful
italian position i'm going for whatever
this is called
i'm just trying to manage my time as
best as possible
hey i'm singer welcome back you're the
best
crash gotham love you too
appreciate it
okay we have some so if he takes i play
b6 it's a nice idea
here this idea of takes i have rookie 5.
if g3
i really want to go crazy but
just move back maybe go for f5
and g3 is a good move
i was gonna play b6 but i guess taking
is also fine
and now b6
don't think i want to trade that was a
good move though
a5
trying to calculate a5
it gets really weird
wait no no i just wondered the rook
ah that was really bad
was like i spent all the time
calculating a different line
okay i have to go for the quick attack
good move
attacking f2 at least
no okay he laundered a rook let's go
oh it's so messy it's so messy
oh it's another rain thanks another
person appreciate the rain
someone give us a shout out if you're
just joining this has been a really
messy game of chess
now we both have almost no time
it might be a draw i don't think he's
going to go for a draw
because the content
also the time
no my knight
never give up
am i not gonna lose this if i don't lose
this it's a miracle
what is this game
am i winning might be winning now
to underpromote tonight
no i'm losing no i'm not with losing am
i
i don't think i'm losing
it's so weird
winning the night let's go
no
oh i saw the queen was aligned with the
king
what was that that was 111 moves
i didn't mean to trade queens i'd just
like to say that that was the
weirdest game ever that was that was
messed up there was so many blunders
but also that's the most brutal game i
ever played
in a while yeah i feel like that was
torture for both of us
i was up a rook then i was down a rook
then i was up at night then we both
then i i you almost made a queen then i
you under promote to another i almost
flagged because
you have to do this keyboard like hold
down alt or control to under promote
and i was just in time uh then you're
under front or two at then we both made
queens we queens at the same time
that was incredible i'm pretty sure i
missed him in there somewhere even after
cleaning
i think you might be able yeah that was
youtube worthy
can we analyze that just for you sure
why not
why not jesus okay uh you want to
analyze on
let's do it on trust.com yeah okay sure
analyze
i think there's you can invite me right
something like that yes
i think uh
and i think you didn't want to fly
because just come you can still flag but
because if it's a queen right even only
chess same thing
um queen
wow look at our accuracy i have a 97 0.7
and you have a 97.2
that's cause with a game uh like over
100 moves like most of the moves were
okay
but uh the blunders kind of get
overshadowed i think
yeah okay um let me see if i
can invite you
oh sorry that's just yeah insane
okay i think i invited you so
this is this is why you know chess is
the most unforgiving game
there is because like especially with
increment it's a psychological
torture and then psychologically it was
so like this queen v8
was so bad like i was trying i initially
wanted to play queen
b7 to the fen b6 but i saw my rook with
hing
i think one plus one might be what that
created creator of oneplus one is like
probably so evil the most evil person
like this is the worst time control you
can ever play because
it's not it's just like end my end my
suffering please so
the reason why chess.com has like the
one second increment for title tuesday
and the speed chess championship events
is because they want to prevent
like the dirty flagging situations but
they also don't want the games to take
so so long like they don't want players
to get more time and then it just takes
forever
so it's kind of like the compromise but
then it just makes it really difficult
when we get these situations
makes sense makes sense yeah that was an
insane game
yeah it got it it woke me up
i was go i don't need coffee anymore
okay so i'm sorry i invited you
oh you're right you're right okay yeah
there we go i was in the wrong window
okay
so yeah was it was that a mouse lip
queen be it or did you actually no
so i i initially was going to play queen
b7
i saw this rook was hanging i didn't
really make the
realization my queen's tied down to both
rooks
gotcha so in hindsight i should probably
just take the pawn
yeah yeah um actually the thing i was
trying to calculate was queen eight
this is what i spent most of my time on
it yeah and then the problem is after it
takes
takes beast hanging yeah or or yeah that
too
and then i want it to or i can take the
rook and then take on easy e8 and then
be surprised
that's a good point yeah it just doesn't
work for me yeah um
wow um
okay and then yeah and then i'll just
skip through the i mean it was just
really i mean i shouldn't have lost my
mind then you lost well you lost a rook
i didn't take it initially
yeah maybe you didn't believe that i
could blunder my rook i guess when you
play queen e2
i just saved my knights oh yeah yeah
that's
that's what i was going so it worked out
for me yeah and then and then you're
better and then somehow i got my queen
in the infiltrated yeah infiltrated and
of course
i thought i was mating you here yeah i
thought i was going to need it too
but you just treat queens yeah i in
hindsight why the heck did i change
queens right just playing
just push the pawn yeah end games are
very hard
and then you should just be easily
winning here yeah i
um your king was surprisingly nifty it
got active
yeah because once i win the default i
mean it's still waiting for you
but with a few seconds left look at how
bad the technique is i played one
two to go three four but i could just go
one two three
yeah you took the longer power i was
trying to help my pawn
and attack your pawn at the same time
which is logical
yeah and i can't do both
um and yeah and then you we both made
queens and it's funny i thought you were
waiting here but luckily i have this
fork right
the problem is yeah i get forked in like
it's like really a jaw
i think it's just to draw but i wow i
see the um
okay i can't see the analysis but yeah
i'll trust you on this one oh actually
it says i'm winning after
king f2 oh because i have a c
pawn oh yeah c4 yeah i've seen
oh my gosh but then you you have oh i
covered d3
so you're too slow so it is waiting for
you or did i mess up something it is
winning
wow yeah and games are so tricky
with one second left and then when you
made a night i was i was gonna laugh
but i didn't have time to think to laugh
but it was so well it's
i've seen these situations before where
it's a very rare case where you under
promote to stop a night fork
i've had this once in a tournament game
i should use this once to like win a
tournament game
um but here yeah it's only moved to
oh actually wait no i'm still i'm still
winning if i play king e3
oh you can repeat the whole thing again
yeah i see that okay but that might have
been a three-fold repetition i'm not
sure but okay
and he'll be three-fold at that point
but yeah uh
i could just take the pawn and jaw
immediately wait am i winning
you're winning here oh no oh no but the
well the only winning move oh okay
wait engine said it was plus eight now
it's saying it's a draw
wait what okay so it takes takes
oh it takes night night goes first don't
take the knight that's it
actually that's that's a nice line i
have to play here yeah okay okay
yeah i can't see the engine for
something because i think it's your your
study
but yeah knight f3 is very clever wow if
i take this it's um
game over right night's too slow and
once again for the chat if you go here
always go two squares
yeah just checking distance and the same
thing for here always go two squares
exactly a lot of common everything is
connected right like in the
like in life um life is just one big
circle
one big yeah pretty much and then i mean
that was only half the game
pretty much yeah and there's another we
both cleaned at the same time and i
thought i'm winning here because
i i for sure thought that you were gonna
blunder well not really when you started
thinking
because it was bullet i thought you
would blunder king here and i would win
your queen
well at first i thought every move was
losing
because if i move to the well i don't if
i move here i lose
but uh okay i found king c3 just in time
yeah and then i could make a draw but i
was so upset of
you know the momentum i mean in my mind
i'm still kind of playing for a win
so i just played check and i thought
that i could trick you with uh
well night the knight in queen situation
with no other pieces
i feel like it was good practice to like
play this out yeah yeah
there was i actually solved the puzzle
that i saw in a book
i don't know if you probably have maybe
seen this too like when the queen and
night are like this they're not really
active so there's a chance that my queen
and i could actually
mate you or or end up in a fork but i
think because your night's right here
opposing my night if this night was
somewhere else i might be able to
checkmate you somehow right
so because we have this weird symmetry
like you have a perfect
that yeah perfect defense here i've
i have studied some like queen knight
positions
versus a lone queen um
like there's all these end game studies
where they're like they're very
difficult calculations
but in a bullet game like this it's just
about moving quickly and
trying to put pressure and some of the
forks
yeah no no for some reason i thought i
had 0.7 seconds left but i had
seven seconds left yeah i moved too
quickly because because i and then i
just and i was making like multiple
primos out of habit because i would
think i have points out
and i i think i and people will see in
my stream i was just like making like
knight here
rook queen here lock move something and
then i started realizing that oh i have
seven seconds and not just
point seven seconds so yeah you had more
time than me
yeah and i was trying like i couldn't
figure out how to gain time
and actually i was very careful not to
play something like this
sure yeah keep your king far away yeah
oh man and then
then i just allowed the queen trade much
much later
yeah what a game good game
yeah hello to youtube